foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host George Campbell
Join This Hour by my good friend Mr Ken
Coleman and we are taking your calls
about life money career purpose work at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five in case you missed it it's been an
amazing week with a lot of uh fun calls
interesting calls we talked to a couple
who put a hundred and twelve thousand
dollars on credit cards for their
wedding uh we had Rachel Rachel Cruz and
Jade pictures turned out well goodness
gracious I asked if her if the ring
looked like a disco ball no joke so uh
we had Jade warshaw and Rachel Cruz host
together for the first time I saw that I
was passing through the lobby and I saw
it I was like now that's what Thelma and
Louise should have looked like that was
yeah the spicy spicy show Jade had an
epic rant about car payments that were
over a thousand dollars I know Ken
you're very passionate uh about the
insanity of car loans and how they're
keeping Americans broke and Ken and I
covered Bucky's
um and their amazing pay and benefits
and their culture and my first Bucky's
experience so it's been a fun week of
segments and shows you can check out all
of those if you missed it on podcast or
on YouTube and on top of that in case
you missed it we had an incredible event
just Steps From Here in our Atrium The
Building Wealth in 2023 live stream we
had about six seven hundred people in
the crowd hundreds of thousands tuning
in online and Ken that was a blast I'm
still a little sleepy I feel like a
fever dream yeah I got out of here last
night about 10 minutes to 10 and back in
this morning and uh the Little Fox News
uh appearance and so it feels though
I've been here for 48 Hours wow and
we're locked in but we're excited it was
a I will tell you it was a special night
uh really great stuff you and Dave and
Rachel did a great job with some some
great Keynotes and then we had a fun
conversation with uh John and I joined
John Delaney and I joined in and we had
a lot a lot of laughs a little too much
fun was had and if you want to see what
we're talking about not possible well
you can't have too much fun it was
borderline off the rails at times I
think we could admit that not true wow
now you're gonna have to watch it you
have to watch the delay to see who's
right George well hey the good news is
if you missed it you've got the fomo you
can still tune in you can go to
ramseysolutions.com wealth and catch the
replay over there love it yeah let's get
to the phones Sarah is waiting in Denver
Colorado Sarah welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me on absolutely
how can we help today
so my fiance and I are going to get
married a little bit later
I actually was married previously and
got a divorce and he is now
um in the picture and I have had a
significant amount of assets
um over time like we have similar
salaries now but I've just had a decent
time to like pile mine up and so
although from like a family and marriage
perspective we do want to take like what
you guys could just talk about of
merging our finances and treating it as
like an us uh you know group and and how
do we buy a house and so forth but I
also bring like quite a bit of cash and
like brokerage accounts and so forth I
could use for either the down pavement
or even like buying a house outright and
so I was kind of curious your advice
about when one person has a significant
amount it's like you will protect
yourself I mean I did go through a
divorce before but at the same time I
don't want to go into my marriage like
thinking of the quote-unquote worst case
scenario
um well that's a it's a reasonable thing
to be thinking about because of you know
the hurt you felt in the past divorces
one of the most difficult things a
person can go through and it can scar
you when it comes to the way you view
money and of course we talk about this
is we this is our money once you're
married combine all the accounts
um and the only time we would recommend
a prenup is if you are coming in with
you know astronomical assets compared to
the other person and it's more to keep
the crazy family at Bay versus a
distrust in the other person so what
kind of assets are we talking about give
give us some numbers
so I have about 2 million between like
retirement accounts and I had sold my
previous house that I owned with my
ex-husband and walked away
um with a bit of cash from that and so
like I'm sitting on just from like a
cash standpoint over half a million
dollars and then on this side do I want
to buy the next house do I want to put
that in the market not just rush into a
decision he on the other hand probably
has more like five hundred thousand
dollars so again neither one of us is
like at any hurt from a financial
perspective but when it comes to you
know buying a house that was not
something he was like initially planning
for so it's more tied up in like Oak
Ridge and stocks and with the stock
market going down it's like how do we
get to something where like I could buy
our house but I want him to feel like he
has skin in the game but at the same
time yeah like I usually we totally want
to try to merch but yeah but here's the
deal time keeping in mind Sarah Sarah
I'm sorry to interrupt but I think we
really got to dive in here
what are you most afraid of
I don't think you're calling for
strategy I could be wrong are you
calling for strategy about how we merge
all this and how we do this or are you
worried about something
I think it's more like I
Sarah don't edit you're trying to edit
and listen I get it but we're here to
help and if you just tell me what you're
feeling right now we can help faster
tell me stop editing what are you
thinking that you didn't say what are
you worried about
the main thing I would be worried about
is like if for some reason the marriage
shouldn't work out like I on one hand I
would want to make sure that this
significant amount of money is still
being recognized as mine especially so
all right so stop so stop so stop okay
the answer to the question is you are
worried that the marriage is not going
to work out
the money stuff is secondary
do you understand I would say I'm
worried about being stupid honestly if I
was gonna like get really to the to the
butt of it okay which is not going to
work out I think there's an element of
like I don't want to be the stupid
person
wait a second what would have to be true
and I want you to give me a specific
answer what would have to be true for
you to be stupid
yeah I would have to go sideways for
some reason and the marriage would not
have to work out the marriage is going
to work
there's also a secondary opponent of
like I'm wanting him to not feel like
like I bought stuff I had the money at
the beginning and therefore it's
quote-unquote now now we're getting
there
Sarah now we're getting there
more money than he does and that freaks
you out a little bit and you're worried
about it that's really what I'm hearing
so this is pre-marriage counseling this
is a good old-fashioned steak and
candlelight dinner and you look at him
and you go I'm worried that you're gonna
feel this way and this way and this way
because when we bring our finances
together I'm bringing more to the table
than you do you feel that way I George I
think this is a communication
relationship pre-marital therapy thing
and get this thing solved and get this
out of your head and then when we merge
the finances we walk the baby steps out
we live that way I think it's gonna be
fine yeah I don't see it as a skin in
the game or adding up who's bringing
what to the marriage it's about
commitment it's about Unity it's about
shared vision and I think once you focus
on that instead of the numbers it will
give you some peace I'm gonna gift you
guys Financial Peace University because
I think it will give you confidence in
your own Futures together as a newlywed
couple hang on the line Austin will give
that to you I'm wishing you the best
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined this hour by Ken
Coleman and we are taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Ken is here to help you answer
those purpose questions work career all
of that and there's so many of that out
there Ken people are going is now the
time I got the toxic boss I think it's
my time to go yeah what what's the
general sentiment out there along the
workforce the general sentiment is is
that millions and millions of people
change jobs they call it the great
resignation over the last year and a
half was over 70 million about 4 million
people a month staggering numbers and so
what that means is when all those people
change jobs for a bigger paycheck they
left a lot of people behind
and so then it kept perpetuating itself
we're like well Fred left and got a
bigger paycheck I'm leaving and that's
continuing to happen so I think a lot of
people are now going well I heard that
they weren't happy when they left so
should I stay should I go I think
there's a lot of angst about the pending
recession that the news loves to scare
the crap out of us with you know so I
just think there's a sense of uneasiness
and and as the as the Ramsey personality
it focuses on work working for income
and working for impact the difference
you want to make in the world
um I'm here on the Ken Coleman show here
today to just steady your nerves give
you some uh practical knowledge and then
give you some confidence that hey I can
take care of this I can control this
Washington DC has nothing to do with my
future I love that well hey if you've
got questions of that nature we'd love
to hear them at triple eight eight two
five five I should point out that I'm
extra serious Today George do you know
why I'm extra serious why is that I've
got the cardigan on that is very serious
Ken he's he's he means business I mean
you're borderline Mr Rogers right now
the only thing I'm missing is a pipe
that would add a little bit of flair too
so let's let's help some people all
right let's get into it well Ken I want
to get to this uh video that we stumbled
across as you know I like to get riled
up by watching videos on social media
you're in the rabbit hole you like to
get on the old internet but it's for the
good of the people well I got I gotta
have my finger on the pulse of what
they're watching boy I tell you do you
ever and they're sending me the videos
going hey what do you think about this
is this well I'm gonna tell you what I
think well Ken hasn't seen the video
folks full disclosure I'm seeing it the
same time you are well uh let's see what
the internet is is stirring up today
when it comes to real estate investing
and why this is the best asset class
this is about as simple as I can make it
we're doing a light rehab and my
flooring guy asked me said Jason why are
you all laying on real estate and why
are you not investing in stocks and
Bitcoin I said that's a great question
Mike do you have a 401k I asked him he
said yes I have 200 000 in my 401k I
said great job that's better than most
scenario number one your dad gets sick
you have to take him to a nursing home
their charging seven thousand dollars a
month to keep them there with your two
hundred thousand dollars in your 401k
how long can you keep them there he
thought about it for a moment 28 and a
half months that's not a long time for
being in a nursing home scenario number
two your dad gets sick you still got to
take him to the nursing home and they're
still charging seven thousand dollars a
month but instead of having two hundred
thousand dollars in a 401k account you
took that 200 Grand and bought 10 cash
flowing assets that produce ten thousand
dollars a month how long can you keep
them there he thought about it and said
forever and that's the power of Real
Estate
all right so that was a fast-moving hard
charging real estate Guru right there
Ken yeah and this is the problem with
the tick tock World we're in YouTube I
love it we're on all the things okay but
it's like if I'm gonna take something
and that complex
that serious
and I'm gonna reduce it to a bunch of
jump Cuts in a video and go when it's
done like I've just taken care of your
day come on this is this is Click bait
stuff oh this is this is cotton candy
what got me sadly a lot of people are
like oh yeah you're right I gotta dump
my 401k and go buy a property right now
this is essentially what he just said
this guy probably has a whole lot more
knowledge and experience I don't want to
bang on this guy because I you say
anything in this world now this is going
to go out there and then yeah we said
something one time about somebody who
gave silly advice
and and the lady wanted to debate me
online
I I got news for you I don't care what
you think
this segment involves what I think and
what I think is this is Click bait it is
surface advice that can get people
really hurt George you know this why
well what happens when you take that
advice and you don't know what you're
doing so this whole fast talking thing
is to get you to do basically nothing
down real estate it's like down as
little as possible cash flowing assets
what that's the hot ticket item right
there Ken if you hear that online run
those guys have an online course to sell
you I promise you he does cash flowing
assets that's what it's all about don't
invest your 401k you got to get nothing
down real estate because then your
tenants will just pay your mortgage and
you'll be a millionaire in no time yeah
no brainer you can't jump cut your way
to financial success that's what that
was tweet that there you go whoever's on
Twitter who's that whoever is left over
there well here's the deal Ken yes I
thought that was pretty good he totally
faked the scenario where the flooring
guy is going hey why aren't you
investing completely yeah the flooring
that never happened second of all this
weird thing about what if you're your
dad's in the nursing home and you got to
pay for the nursing home I don't
understand why that's the scenario he
goes to but it's called long-term care
George we always recommend long-term
care because of that scenario so talk to
your parents if you've got someone who's
in the elderly stage and they may be
going you've got to get long-term care
in place to cover this number one and we
don't know Dad may have a bunch of
retirement why is this on you don't set
your kids up in that way to where
they've got to tank their 401k and the
other point I have is that your 401k
creates cash it's invested and with an
average eight ten twelve percent it
makes money and you can get as close to
a guarantee with that you can't
guarantee that you're going to be able
to buy 10 houses and they turn into all
this so you talk about because they're
talking about spinning off rent oh and
the renters just magically pay perfectly
every month and don't damage the place
in the HVAC and the roof and everything
just stays perfectly fine yeah so let's
what do you think the average you know
what let's have some fun with this
George this strategy which by the way
the only thing missing on the end of
that video was hey buy my product so you
can buy your dad a castle on the beach
with a hot nurse I mean that literally
was the last thing needed too we may
have cut him off early he may have gone
into that yeah it might have got into
that uh what do you think the average
person running that strategy what do you
think they're making on rent well you
gotta imagine they've got 500 bucks
they've got very little equity in a
property yeah they've got the mortgage
to pay right plus maintenance plus HOA
plus expenses plus their insurance and
after that their net profit is very much
but let's just pick a number to to
because what I don't want to do is
critique this and not help you see the
other side of it so let's say they're
making between George you're the math
guy most people are making 100 to 800
bucks you're clearing that you think
they're clearing that that's right from
callers that call in who have investment
property with mortgages on if they say
well we're making about 10 grand on it
would you say so the net would be
between five and eight hundred bucks
that's fair all right so times 12 months
yeah so you're talking six grand eight
grand versus 10 grand versus investing
money in a 401k over the same amount of
time well you got 200 bucks on a 401K
and you get a return of 10 on that 200k
that's 20 grand that year that you
didn't have to do anything by the way
yeah you have to mop the floor talk to a
tenant who's got more cats than they do
since I mean you don't have to do that I
mean this is real numbers absolutely and
here's the thing we love real estate
around here Dave's got a lot of it but
he paid cash for it which changes the
way you view it and the return on that
investment is astronomical compared to
you trying to keep up and pay the
mortgage and net profit on that thing
and so you want to talk about cash
flowing assets pay cash for that
investment property and add up what that
amounts to you see that's not in the
video the video doesn't explain how it
takes for all that rental income to
equal this the amount of money that he's
promising absolutely and the risk
involved
so here's the deal the more boring it
sounds the more I'm excited about it
because I feel like oh I could do that
when it comes to handling you know 10
pieces of real estate with nothing down
that's a lot of anxiety in my life while
trying to work a full-time job here's an
old old saying I don't know who said it
George
if it looks or sounds too good to be
true
it probably is and that's the
click-baity stuff that we got to be
careful about how in the world can
someone give you this unbelievable sound
financial advice in a one minute Tick
Tock or whatever it ends up being I just
I would tell you folks it's cotton candy
well Our advice hey once you're out of
debt and have an emergency fund invest
15 into your 401k sounds boring and
guess what it's the number one
investment vehicle to becoming a
millionaire based on the 10 000 that we
studied
do with that information what you will
and by the way you can have a great 401k
and invest in real estate with cash and
a nice cardigan and a great cardigan to
match there you go this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
and we're also joined by a lovely couple
on the debt free stage we've got
Fernando and Miriam with us how are you
guys doing good doing great where are
you guys from Fort Lauderdale wonderful
and you guys are debt free how much you
pay off we paid off a hundred and forty
one thousand and ninety dollars wow and
how long did that take uh 46 months
awesome and what was your range of
income during that time we started off
uh at a hundred and ten thousand and
just uh wrapped up last uh year around
uh 250 000. whoa okay hold on Story Time
gotta dig in there what happened what
was the cause or who were the causes of
that increase in income so it was a
couple things so promotions between the
both of us nice change jobs uh side
hustles lots of Huss side hustles so I
worked full-time in and then I did
worked part-time at Target I uh picked
up uh I did some shifts with shipped to
deliver groceries and sold items on
Poshmark way to go in addition to Target
yes what do you mind me asking what you
made in your side hustle at Target what
was your hourly rate do you mind sharing
the hourly rate was 15 an hour which
that does pretty cool it I I say this
every day on the Ken Coleman show if you
just need something to get through you
did it as a side hustle to get out of
debt yeah let me tell you something
folks 15 an hour Target what were you
doing I was the
um I worked at Guest Services so I kind
of moved around wherever they needed me
I made myself available so I get more
hours and learn different areas of okay
folks poster child for the opportunity
that exists right now in the United
States and I just want to point it out
good on you guys you just went after it
but the opportunity is there to get
through the baby steps faster is it not
absolutely yeah that's great that's
awesome so what kind of debt was this
141 oh just a bunch of normal stuff so
credit cards uh our wedding uh two cars
and uh the student loans wow and a
partridge and a pear tree to add to that
oh my goodness so 46 months ago this
changed how long you guys been married
uh we celebrated four years this past
July hey it's exciting so we're talking
like you came back from the honeymoon
and you're like all right time to stop
being broke yeah basically and we we've
been following the Dave Ramsey Show for
you know about a year before we got
married and we had a conversation we
always wanted to be debt-free and uh to
be honest the first two years we did a
ish plan and it wasn't until about March
of 2020 where we did FPU through our
local church in Tampa Florida where we
were living at the time and uh that's
where everything just got serious we did
the first session and we looked at each
other like look we need to stop doing
our plan and follow the the plan and um
just submit to the process and uh that
same week we took what was in our
savings besides a thousand dollars and
paid off uh her car uh you know the
phones that we that we owed and uh some
other stuff and then how much I got to
ask you this because a lot of people
wrestle with this part of the plan when
we take calls and I want to dive in here
how much was in savings that you just
emptied to get to a thousand dollars to
truly do baby step one how much I think
it was uh about twelve thousand all
right so I have two questions how
freaking scary was that to do that I was
ready
I you know stability security it scared
me so much if it wasn't for me we would
have done it sooner all right so now the
second question is once you did that and
we've put eleven thousand dollars we
paid off your car and some cell phones
if I recall what did that feel like for
you on the other side because you were
the one that were afraid Miriam so what
did it feel after we did that with the
11. so worth it oh just so worth it
Freedom even just a little bit yeah not
the freedom I feel now because now that
we're completely debt-free it's just
another I don't have a word for it but
it's starting to feel the freedom that
would come I'm gonna give you a word for
how it feels good yeah that's good
definitely you guys are amazing see that
that switch flipped and you just went
all in obviously you were working
multiple side jobs what was the hardest
part for you guys on this journey for
four years
I'm playing this week for you uh I guess
uh getting on board 100 with the Dave
plan um really really I can't speak
enough of the small group we had in
March 2020 um the craft family let it
they let it so well we became good
friends after that um we told them we
were here they're so excited for us and
um I guess it's hard to stay on track
because you have to say no to a lot of
good things
um to wait for great things and so watch
out just drop that what was the hardest
thing to say no to what was the thing
you're like gosh we're on this plant we
can't we just can't we missed out on
every other family uh vacation so like
my my brother and uh old family lives in
Texas and so they had like these cabin
trips and these bigger things that
happened and we just had to say no to
him like sorry we can't go we're on a
plan we also had to push back our Europe
trip that we had planned it was canceled
originally because of covid but then it
didn't feel right to do if we weren't
debt free and it was that much sweeter
when we got to go in September of this
year after becoming debt free
European vacations
credit card and you would have Justified
it by going well we got some cash back
out of the deal yes we're winning it was
all paid for and it was just coming back
knowing that we didn't have to put on a
credit card just it was cash flow we
were like that was great now we could
just you know and get ready for the
holidays and enjoy that too so wow yeah
and there's such power in going through
that Financial Peace class in person
with real people yes because when you
don't show up they're texting you going
hey what the heck guys we would love to
see you why didn't you show up and so
there's such accountability built in and
you go oh we're not alone we're not the
only ones sacrificing we're not crazy
for doing this thing absolutely
definitely just uh for us it just gave
us the the discipline and having those
conversations and I think for another
thing that happened during uh when we
took a few we did the envelope system we
weren't doing that before and when we
just take the cash out and like if the
envelope's empty like you can't use it
anymore like okay well that's that
that's it until the next time a poor
restaurant and groceries envelope's
falling apart right now oh my goodness I
might have to pick up a wallet yeah but
what I think we know somebody I think we
can get
by the way I have the spiritual gift of
giving away Dave's stuff love it I want
to point that out so you guys did this
stuff there's another couple out there
who probably just got married and
they're sitting there with a pile of
debt and payments what do you tell them
to actually get them on board with this
plan it's it's totally worth it
um the the piece that you get from
paying off your debts and the freedom
there's nothing that can really just you
know you can't you just have to
experience and feel it uh so actually a
thing that happened to to us I was laid
off in December and when I received that
news that I was you know going through
you know a layoff for me it was kind of
like okay this is uh interesting but it
didn't feel like complete panic mode it
felt like well we paid off our debts we
have our six months emergency fund
funded we're gonna be okay we're gonna
be fine so we got I got home we sat down
together we looked at the budget and
like
we we were able to just know that we're
gonna be okay and we're not gonna
struggle and we're gonna get through
this and if I have to go to Target or
anywhere else to pick up a job it's
gonna be fine
um hey I've got to ask you about that so
you had Financial Freedom that gave you
a different type of Freedom yeah
freedom to choose where I want to work
yes
am I right yeah by the way we're not
panicking I'm not acting out of urgency
I'm acting out of uh intentionality
correct wow I think also what I would
tell someone who's newly married is that
it's very important to live below your
means because we choose to live that way
we didn't even have to dip into the
emergency fund because we can survive
off of one income
and it was a time that for vacation for
him for the last month he did actually
turn down an offer not once but twice
after they came back because it didn't
feel right wow which is interesting and
very difficult but we really trusted God
in that season yeah but again the
confidence that comes from Freedom yes
no desperation yes exactly I'm so proud
of you and you guys have a resilience
where you're not victims anymore you're
not whiners you just go oh we have
opportunity we can just go get a job
correct we'll do whatever it takes we'll
live on less than we make yeah it turns
out it's a great negotiating tactic as
well you're not even trying to negotiate
you're like no what a flex I'm good well
yeah nice Flex we are so proud of you
guys we've got the live and give box for
you which includes The Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires as well
as a year of Financial Peace University
you can use that or give it away to
someone to get them started on their
journey and we are so honored to have
you guys let's get to the moment we've
all been waiting for it's Fernando and
Miriam a hundred and forty one thousand
dollars paid off and 46 months making
110 up to 250 multiple side jobs living
on less than they made counted down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one we're debt free
yes they are
another Dead Bites the Dust Ken so I
like nothing can stop them
no the habits they've got the discipline
they've got the resilience the
perseverance whatever comes their way
they're gonna get through it they didn't
just change their money folks they
changed their life there's so much
evidence of that what a fantastic couple
they're on their way to real Legacy
that's what it's all about you can do it
to America it's available for you this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by my
good friend Ken Coleman and uh Ken it's
a it's a big day today because it's
quitters day apparently oh is it a new
holiday
and a lot of people they've got career
goals they're starting to give up uh and
I thought you could give them some hope
can you do that how about we give them a
tool that's good too you you hope and a
tool okay both hand both hand so
so quitting right like here's what
happens
quitting is an excuse and it makes a lot
of sense when we're in the midst of hard
things so let's just get real about the
baby steps we have a lot of people
watching and listening that are that
that whether they're Dave ish or they're
all in they're in the midst of this
journey right and and I think of baby
step two as the hardest stage it it
clearly is it's brutally hard
um because we we feel bad about
ourselves we got into this mess now we
got to get out and we believe in the
baby steps right people go it makes
sense what they're these folks are
saying on the Ramsey Show and then what
happens is
we get to a point where it gets really
really hard and then when it gets hard I
don't know if you're like me but when
when things get hard marriage
parenting
work
the baby steps life can we just can I
get an amen like life is hard so what
happens for me is is I start to feel
like it's impossible so my emotion
George is that the harder something is
the more unattainable or the more
impossible it becomes and then what
happens is I start to reason I start to
think and logic my way into well if this
is impossible
why am I doing it
and so then what happens is our human
nature we just kind of go well it's the
smart thing to quit
but it's not
it's easy
quitting is easy but quitting's not
smart and so what I found out in my own
life is that the right things are always
hard
being faithful committed to Stacy
for almost 25 years
it's been harder for her than me to be
honest bless her heart but it's hard
it's really hard yeah parenting three
teens is brutally hard all you parents
out there by the way with with little
kids and you think it's hard nope you're
exhausted
just not hard wait till the emotional
your kids are driving they're dating
they're trying to figure themselves out
it's brutally hard brutally hard I'm
just being honest
but those are the right things for me to
be a dad to be a husband right getting
out of debt is brutally hard it's the
right thing for me for my family for my
freedom my livelihood we understand that
and so that's the challenge I want to
encourage people that we come on the
show every day and we answer your
questions and we tell you practically
here's how you get out of debt here's
how you build an emergency fund here's
how you pay for a house cash you know
pay your house up all these things
and
the steps are simple
but it's really hard and I just want to
acknowledge some people today that are
really feeling like they're going to
quit because they don't think they're
ever going to get there well it turns
into a lot of negative self-talk and a
lot of self-doubt and it's a lot of gone
yeah can of course you quit again you're
that kind of guy you know the way we
talk to ourselves we would never talk to
someone else you gotta get back on the
wagon and go that's not that's not my
identity just because I admit I screwed
up the budget once or I'm in a career I
don't love that's not you it doesn't
Define you yeah you can always change
that's right and I think the challenge
is is just if you're doing something
hard and you know it's right
you can't quit now let's just be real if
you're doing something that's really
really hard and you know it's the wrong
thing okay there's your permission quit
that
right yeah but but if it's a right thing
ask yourself is this right is this worth
it if the answer is emphatically yes and
getting out of debt working in a job
that you are good at that you love that
producers results seeing purpose in the
Monday morning that's that's worthy
starting that business that is going to
solve a problem that's very deeply
personal to you maybe from past pain
that's the right thing it's hard
and so I just want to acknowledge George
that some of you are doing some really
hard things right now
and I know what it's like
and it's worth it so don't quit don't
quit just get your eye on the prize
Finish Line one step in front of the
other just one win today
if you win today
then you can win tomorrow and getting
out of debt losing weight starting and
launching and growing a business uh
discovering who you really are in this
world and what it is you want to do
whatever it is fixing your marriage
becoming a better parent rescuing the
heart of your kid who's Wayward I don't
care what it is it is not a get it done
right now it is going to be one step at
a time and so if you're in that know
that we are here for you at Ramsey
Solutions and all the different shows
all the social media accounts the tools
everything we're here because we all
know what it's like including Dave to
walk through the hard times when you
just don't feel like you're ever going
to get over the mountain you will and
we're going to walk alongside of you
that's what I want people to hear I love
it well if you are a new listener which
I know we had several hundred thousand
tune into our live stream if you just
kind of stumbled upon it on YouTube and
you're going who are these people what
is this plan that they're talking about
well if you want to learn about it we
have created an awesome tool for you to
get started all you need to do go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and we will guide you
we'll give you the right tools and
resources based on your answers to the
questions it's a completely free tool
and we want to help help you do that
it's based on your specific situation
because Ken I've heard you say this
Clarity leads to confidence and so many
people just need that Clarity of what is
the tell me exactly what will work show
me that other people have done it show
me that I can too yeah you know that's
really true I want you all to think of a
time where you've been driving you hit
maybe a dense patch of fog to where you
can barely see beyond the hood of the
car or a torrential downpour and you
can't see what do we do we immediately
overcome a fear and we slow down and we
pull off the side of the road why
because we can't see the road and and
not being able to see a clear path
forward to progress and breakthrough in
my life means I become paralyzed and so
Clarity does lead to confidence and this
is the best part confidence leads to
courage
when I'm clear that I can get out of
debt and live like no one else so that
later I can live
and work and give like no one else
that gives me confidence to step out on
the path
but then the courage to stay on the path
when life throws its curves and potholes
and challenges at us all right it shakes
us and what do we do we Retreat back to
clarity
oh I blew it this month wait a second
what's the key to winning a baby step
two right get back to the snowball right
get back get back in I get clear I gotta
get some momentum and so that's that's
the idea Clarity leads to confidence and
confidence leads to courage well Ken you
I got a tool called get clear which I
think is apt for for this segment right
here sure sure so for those that maybe
are in the careers they're they're going
this isn't it whatever I'm doing right
now for work it ain't it I need to get
that Clarity so that I'm confident so
that I have the courage what does this
tool do so here it is folks if you had
20 minutes
to be able to fully see yourself as you
are what you are good at what you love
to do and what motivates you what if I
told you in 20 minutes you could get
real clear answers on that and then
those answers turn into a purpose
statement that become essentially a job
description an overarching job
description of the professional
contribution that you were put on this
Earth to make where you increase your
income and increase your impact money
and meaning that's the tool it's a great
tool check it out ramseysolutions.com
get clear
ramseysolutions.com get clear it's the
get clear career assessment and it's not
about you just getting a good job it's
about you making the difference that you
were put on this Earth to make and uh
again we went through mine on the show
recently and it was like reading I mean
you were reading my mail I was shocked
at how accurate this thing was not on
just like listing out potential career
paths which were literally what I'm
doing today but also giving me a purpose
statement that helped me go that's how
I'm wired that's right and that's
self-awareness a lot of self-aware
person is a confident person
now you're not trying to keep up with
the Joneses on Instagram or try to do
the business that your cousin did you're
like no no I'm I'm being me I'm doing me
baby and we gotta we got millions and
millions and millions of people in this
country that John deloney's helping that
are dealing with anxiety depression of
all sorts and it's because they don't
know who they are we know a lot about a
lot of things in this world you know we
don't know enough of who we are and what
we're supposed to do with our life
that'll pray so we're here to help the
get clear assessment check it out
ramseysolutions.com well strong way to
end the hour thank you Ken good stuff
here thank you to all the folks in the
booth for keeping the show afloat we got
Austin and will and James and all sorts
of people in there and of course you
America we thank you so much for tuning
in don't go anywhere we'll be back real
soon
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm George Campbell
Ramsey personality joined by
best-selling author and host of the Ken
Coleman show you guessed it Ken Coleman
himself in the building taking your
calls about work purpose career and
everything in between the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five Susie's kicking us off in
Charlotte North Carolina Susie welcome
to the show
hi guys thanks for your time today
absolutely how can Ken and I help I
think it's a simple question I think I
might know the answer but it's always
good to get the reassurance uh I'm
currently on baby step number two of
which um my main focus is an eight
thousand dollar car loan
um said car is a little sick and is
going to need a new transmission in the
near future
ouch yes I know uh it could be maybe two
weeks it could be two months or maybe
another year but it is coming and I
would like to try to prepare for it
um with the six thousand dollar
projected expense ahead I did receive
luckily a thirty five hundred dollar
bonus that um I really wanted to send
towards the loan but was curious should
I pause the baby steps uh apply that
3500
towards the the new transmission and
work to building that success 1000 and
then resume the baby step
um I the the big thing you want to think
about here is I don't want to go further
into debt and so if you've got you know
a thousand bucks in the bank and you
know this transmission is going to cost
six then we need to make sure we're
prepared for that since you know it's
coming so I would be pausing that baby
step until we have that situation under
control what's what's the car worth I'm
just concerned this isn't worth it at
all
uh yeah I know that's my other concern I
I it's not going to be I'm going to be
putting 6000 into a car that's not worth
it but
um it I would be going into debt to get
a new a new car or different what is the
car
um it's a Buick SUV Kelly Blue Book
currently is about eight thousand so if
even with the transmission issue no that
was before
um who quoted you who'd you get your
quote from on the six thousand dollars
for a Buick transmission
uh a local
um uh service guy and I also have a
second quote coming
um hopefully today or tomorrow I'm a
little skeptical of that and I'm no
Gearhead shocking to anybody who knows
me but uh I recently had a a 2006 Lexus
and uh I was driving it I wanted to
drive it until it died and the
transmission started to go and I was in
that boat where it was probably worth
with a healthy transmission about six
thousand dollars and I took it to a
local transmission shop here and uh they
quoted me 3 800 for it so I'm just a bit
suspicious I'm not saying that you're
being lied to but I like a second and a
third opinion I I just don't understand
why a Lexus transmission would be less
than a Buick transmission and at that
point you start to go all right if it's
I got to spend three or 35 or 38 or 4
000.
um then then you decide and for me I was
in a situation where you know I could go
just cash flow and I Was preparing for
it blah blah blah but like honestly my
kid didn't want it if my kid had wanted
it I would have put the 3 800 in it in a
minute you know and just been like boom
there you go because now he's got his
car so right that's where I'm at I you
know it's gonna you know if it's truly 6
000 but the cars aren't worth that it's
the question is how many more years can
you get out of it with a fresh
transmission and if you can get three
four five six years it's still worth it
to me George yeah especially if you're
not going to recoup the costs on this
thing which you obviously want in the
scenario so I'm thinking first of all
get a second quote a quick Google search
showed me that it should be more like
eighteen hundred to four grand for
something like that so six feels like
they're taking you to the cleaning
I was suspicious that's a Google search
so you know take it with a grain of the
grain of salt but your your year your
model and uh I yeah I 6 000 seems really
high so if you've got the second uh
quote that comes in I'm expecting is a
little more uh digestible yeah so how
much do you have in the bank right now
do you have a thousand bucks
I have that plus the 3 500. okay and
you're doing the monthly budget you're
covering the four walls food utility
shelter Transportation with your future
paychecks yes okay yeah so I would also
start looking into what would it look
like to buy a really cheap you know it's
going to be a high mileage piece of junk
that hopefully still reliable an old
Honda or Toyota that could get you by
instead of sinking all this money into
this Buick so that's another option to
look into to use that bonus towards okay
uh that's fair and actually here I come
with more Ken stories oh so the same
Lexus I was just talking about
I listed it for twenty five hundred
dollars on Facebook Marketplace and I
said the transmission is on its way out
it is drivable uh you can drive it
anywhere you want to I drove it today
but it's going you know running I just
told the truth I said this is a deal and
I got I got I sold it for two
so if you were to do that for the Buick
let's say you do the same thing and you
got two to Georgia's point now you got
to figure out transportation in that
time and if you could take your 3 500
plus whatever you made out of the Buick
now we can get ourselves a reasonable
used car to get us through baby step two
and three so that's an option too that's
what I would personally be leaning
towards because it hurts emotionally to
sink that much money into this Buick
that's not even going to be worth six
grand eight grand when you put that
money into it let's be honest it hurts
it hurts to put any amount of money it
hurts oh gosh and that just is a great
reminder that cars are depreciating
assets that are just going to die on you
so don't sink too much money into this
stuff uh but Susie I hope that helps
answer your question you've got a little
bit of homework to do uh before we can
give you a real clear answer but I'm
leaning towards just buying a different
used car
which is very very helpful absolutely
thanks for the call all right Tyson
joins us up next in Dallas Tyson welcome
to the show
hey thanks for taking the call guys
absolutely let's get right to the
question we're up against the clock here
yeah
um so I'm looking to pay off my debt in
a couple months and I'm going into baby
step three after that I'm trying to
figure out the way to tell where on the
range of three to six months I should be
for the savings okay are you a single
uh I'm engaged we'll be married by that
time oh cool and what are you doing for
work
I do Cloud engineering
that sounds sweet a pretty stable job
Stable Company
yes we actually had good profit this
year awesome and is your wife to be
working
she is she's a full-time librarian that
feels pretty stable
yes so I would in this scenario you
could lean towards those three months
because you're going to be married with
two stable incomes now if you had a
regular income or seasonal or you're a
single parent or you're married with one
income then I would lean towards that
six
gotcha
does that help you
yeah so start calculating what are all
of our Bare Bones expenses we need to
get by now you can add the luxuries in
there if you want to be able to live
three months and keep your life as is
but it helps to know the variance
between them to make that decision on
what that number should be but man
you're on the path that's awesome
congratulations
all right we're taking your calls Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
your life your money I'm George Campbell
he's Ken Coleman this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Ken Coleman this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money
well Building Wealth in this economy you
might be wondering is it possible we
keep hearing that question and we get
your confusion there's tons of noise out
there right now about inflation and
layoffs and Rising interest rates and
you deserve answers and that's why we
blew up the internet we packed the house
last night right here in Nashville
Tennessee at our Building Wealth live
stream event and if you missed it don't
worry because we are coming to a city
near you we're taking this thing back on
the road that's right Dave Ramsey myself
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney Rachel Cruz
Jade warshaw Christina Ellis were
splitting up the gang all over for our
Building Wealth live spring tour where
we're going to dig into all these hot
topics and we're going to give you a
proven plan to build wealth and keep it
where are we going George we are going
to Indianapolis on February the 16th you
are I'll be there Ken you're going to be
in Austin Texas yeah we're the weird
people you are and the good barbecue oh
I'm sad I'll miss that February 23rd in
Austin then I'll be back out in Salt
Lake City on April 24th and then you'll
round us out in Anaheim yeah Mickey
Mouse ears on for that one nice little
spring Disney vacation for the Coleman's
I think is oh is that what you think I'm
spoiling if your kids are listening
right now which I know they listen every
show you do no they're teenagers they
don't even uh listen to anything I say
much less the show they don't listen to
anything you say on air let alone in the
house yeah golly man no they're good
kids they're the best it's just dad
jokes bad dad jokes they weren't even
here to hear it so they don't listen to
the show though I promise you that yeah
yeah
oh by the way it's a guarantee not to
ever think too highly of yourself just
have teenagers well I heard we'll keep
you humble Will Ferrell's kids don't
think he's funny and I saw that that
gave me great I saw that interview it
made me feel better I could come in from
some like National media hit New York or
whatever and I'm all excited about it
and my kids are like yeah whatever dude
whatever all right we're out of the
cheese go get us some cheese your cringe
you're cringy you give us the ick I'm
cringy so now I lean into it yeah right
so if that's cringy I'm gonna do more of
it that's part of fatherhood yeah well
comes out on the show every once in a
while George keeps me in line I try to
keep Ken young that's what I'm here for
so if you want to join us for Building
Wealth in any of those cities
Indianapolis Austin Salt Lake City
Anaheim tickets start at just 49 bucks
or you can get a four pack of tickets
starting at 175. bring your friend
friends find some if you got to do that
it's going to be amazing
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats now Mark joins us up next in
Richmond Virginia Mark welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey guys taking a call appreciate it
sure what's going on with you uh my wife
and I are currently in uh baby steps six
and we have the question as to whether
we could ever pause lost contributions
to go ahead and pay off the house uh we
contributed about 900 a month into our
Roth and if we pause it for a year we
get the house completely paid off and I
got a one in college that will finish
and we're cash flowing her but then
another one starting college right when
she graduates so just trying to figure
out how to put all these four five and
six steps together
how much are you contributing as a
percentage of your household income
right now into retirement
uh 15 and you want to pause that down to
zero in order to pay off the house
faster
uh pause it down to about uh two or
three percent I've got most of that that
15 going in a Roth but I've got a few
other things that I'm paying into as
well okay I would I would not suggest
that Mark I would continue at 15 and
worry about college later again your
retirement there's a hundred percent
chance that you will need to retire
there's a 50 50 chance that kid gets
through school graduates and they can
get scholarships they can work part-time
there's a lot of options to help them go
to school debt free not a lot of options
for them to help you retire with dignity
and that's what we see a lot here on the
show is the parents sacrifice they're
investing in order to take care of other
things what you're doing great things
right now but then all of a sudden the
kid has to help take care of the parents
because they didn't prepare well for
retirement so I would continue the 15
it's not going to slow you down by that
much how how long does it extend that I
was so close to the mortgage being paid
off oh I know that you're so excited
well if I had to shave it from anywhere
it's not going to be from investing
because you do the the opportunity cost
on you pausing that investing and what
that will turn into in retirement you'll
want to throw up looking at all the
money down the drive I got an idea for
you mark
so 900 a month for a year would pay the
house off so instead of generating that
900 in additional uh mortgage payment by
pausing your 401k or you're off
investing I'm going how can I make
through side hustles selling stuff I
mean 9 times 12 is uh what is that ten
thousand eight hundred dollars last time
I checked again that's real good math
boy folks I had to take my shoes and
socks off for that one uh haven't hit
that multiplication table in a while so
so basically what I'm saying is how can
you generate how can you make ten
thousand eight hundred dollars
multiple ways to pay the house off in
the same time frame but you don't touch
your retirement what do you think
yeah that sounds like a good plan I know
man that's why I suggested it what if
you have two thousand dollars worth of
stuff in your house now we only got to
come up with hold on a second eighty
eight hundred dollars oh boy I'm getting
it's it boy I'm really on Amazon Fire
you know that's the idea I I love that
you want to fast forward it but don't
rob it from yourself yeah good good good
good good that's what I was gonna say
yeah I love that and also do a budget
audit and go hey are we overpaying for
insurance we got to shop that around hey
are we always getting a refund every
year let's change some withholdings so
that we have that income back in our
life and you start to do that across the
board and I think you're going to find
that 10 grand what's your household
income
uh about a hundred thousand what do you
do for a living
I'm a pastor
ah Karen loves pastors I'm a pastor's
kid are you handy at all like and do you
even know what I mean by that I'm not
sure I'm saying that properly no okay
neither yeah neither am I my dad was by
vocational he was a pastor of a small
church but whenever we got into some
bigger purchases or things he had to do
my dad was very gifted with and so he
would do a good construction work
handyman work all that kind of stuff my
point is how can you make ten thousand
eight hundred dollars with your skill
set your connections your experience
that's what I'd be doing is your spouse
working outside the home
yes yes that's our combined uh income
okay what do they do
uh she's a a works at a high school okay
is there any way where she might be able
to do some tutoring after school or
Summers
well she's not a teacher she works in
the uh as an administrator on the
administrative side office yeah well
there may be opportunity for her to even
do some side hustles so that you guys
kind of split the weight of this is she
is excited to pay off the mortgage
uh we're both pretty excited to get the
markets paid off well then here it is
it's fifty four hundred dollars each
make it a competition who could come up
with it first who who earns the 5400 100
quicker and then they get to choose the
uh the romantic weekend getaway trip uh
after we pay off the house you go uh
game officiates some weddings maybe oh
there we go with the honorariums that's
an idea oh yeah yeah I've been throwing
all the honorariums that I get through
funerals and weddings at the at the
house I'd be doing every wedding I could
possibly what do you get for a wedding
these days
that's a great question what do you give
me the expectation where you go okay
this is I think this is fair and
generous if someone was willing to do
this much
well
you get paid less for weddings than you
might expect
I'm just looking for a number what's the
number range is the range is between 150
and 300. all right well that's fair now
we start to go how many of those would I
have to do and we we you're limited
obviously so what I'm trying to do is
really take you down the path to I could
come up with fifty four hundred dollars
pretty quickly and my wife could
probably do it as well cleaning houses
doing whatever we got to do if you
really want to knock it out in a year
it's right there in front of you
yeah yeah that's good and by the way
worst case scenario it takes one more
year which is incredible how long was
that whole journey then paying off the
house
oh it's been a while I mean we didn't we
didn't get really kicking it into the
house until really recently when you
start to taste it oh yeah and now you're
in high gear when you got the big x's on
the thousands and you're marking them
off that's when you when you really
start to feel it oh I love it well
that's incredible I especially love
pastors becoming completely debt free
that's incredible Mark we're so proud of
you thankful for the work you're doing
in your community and uh wishing you the
best with the house payoff this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com time
to save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show America
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call you jump in
we'll talk about your life your money
your purpose your work we are here for
you I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour and Laura joins us up
next in Charleston South Carolina Laura
welcome to the show
thank you what's going on
um so my husband and I are retired we
moved from New York to South Carolina
Charleston uh we are completely debt
free and we have a Year's worth of
expenses saved up wow but due to the
yeah
um due to the house sale we have about
500 to invest and we want to know the
best way to do that so did you pay for a
property in cash when you moved to
Charleston
uh yes we did actually
um once we sold the house uh we paid
that off as a second home so yes so you
got two homes
no I sold the one in New York okay so
you're down to a primary residence that
is paid for what's that house worth
uh probably about 400 now all right and
what's in your your nest egg in
retirement
uh we're about 300.
all right is that in like 401ks and IRAs
yeah okay and then aside from that
you've got 500 sitting in cash
yes awesome and what are you guys
planning on to retire on as far as
income
so we have some rental property that we
take home about 50 000. okay so you do
have other properties
yeah and that property is pretty much
what's maintaining us that's why we're
able to be retired all right how many
properties do you have
it's just the one okay and it brings in
50K
yep that's awesome and that one's paid
for
yes it is way to go you guys have done
so well how old are you two
uh 56 and 58. great well it's a it's a
wise question to ask what to do with
this 500 000 I want this money to work
for you long term are you gonna need to
touch this money in the next few years
or is this just hey down the line 10 15
years from now it would be great to have
this money grow for us
uh just down the line
great are you wanting to purchase more
property down the line or do you want
this to just kind of create a return for
you
wow a little bit of all the property has
done well for us so I'm leaning towards
that but I wanted to hear from the
experts I love it well there's a few
options here clearly you guys are
comfortable with rental property real
estate and so it's a great option to
purchase a property if you can get a
kind of a deal on that and you pay for
it in cash if you can find someone
that's you know maybe two three four
hundred dollars four hundred thousand
dollars that can cash flow another 50
for you that's great or the other option
is you put this five hundred thousand
dollars into an index fund or a mutual
fund and with an average return of you
know eight to ten percent that could
also create forty fifty thousand dollars
a year and compound interest right and
so it's really what you're most
comfortable with some people are going
hey I know real estate I'm comfortable
with real estate I don't want to ride
the stock market roller coaster the
house is going to appreciate over the
next 10 years I want to put that in real
estate you could split the difference
you could buy a 250 000 property put the
other 250 in index funds and mutual
funds and watch that grow
yeah so the key is to do one or the
other I wouldn't just leave it sitting
in your bank account at zero percent
interest
well
you got it in a high-yield savings
account
uh yes good good well you guys are doing
so great I would also do you guys have a
good financial advisor you're working
with
we actually are in the middle of
interviewing five of them that came from
your website oh wonderful well I'd get a
second opinion from them as they dig
more into the the details of your
financial picture but I don't think you
can go wrong either way because you guys
are comfortable with real estate I think
that's a great option and I don't think
you can go wrong with a long-term
mindset in the market with a next funds
and mutual funds
mm-hmm okay so I talk it over with your
husband and land on a smartvester pro
and I'm man I just feel this is this is
not the average call we get from folks
that are retiring Ken no I mean and by
the way very young
uh to you George 56 and 58 feels a
little older to me it's like they're 56
58 they've got paid for home Primary
Home paid for rental property that
they're essentially living off of
fifty thousand dollars is spinning off
and they're in really good shape five
hundred thousand dollars in cash
that's a good problem to have check in
the boxes
and I'm just curious I didn't get a
chance to ask her you know moved from
New York to Charleston South Carolina
that's got to be a real change too a
cost of living way less yeah so wow good
for them just a great picture of what it
looks like to live out this plan yeah
and the amount of just peace in her
voice and the amount of wisdom she was
walking with oh yeah inspiring I want to
be like Laura when I grow up love it
let's go on to Bryce in Sacramento Bryce
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thank you so much absolutely what's
going on
uh well I got a lot going on
um I'll start I uh I got married about
four years ago and immediately after
marriage my wife and I found out that
she was diagnosed with multiple
scleroderosis oh so sorry and um thanks
yeah it's it's been a rough go
um
so she needed to stop working for her
health so I've been a Sole Provider
um but I have a hard time finding out
um a career that's right for me and
something I love to do
um and so just trying to keep this
afloat while she goes through her
bachelor's degree which has been
debt-free so far
um
and uh we just got some medical news
yesterday thinking like the future is
going to look pretty rough moving
forward but she's still going to push
forward in school and we have about
fifteen thousand dollars in debt
um just from like credit cards and stuff
um the medical debts kind of off the
charts we we don't even know where it's
at it's gone to collections
um but I'm just trying to figure out a
good way to keep pushing forward and
when I'm I'm working as a landscaper I
haven't found out what I'm passionate
about yet yeah well there's a lot to
cover in this I'm gonna I I want us to
focus in on the money situation first
because I do have a couple tools that I
want to give you I want you to have the
get clear career assessment in my book
from paycheck to purpose because it
really will help you get some clarity
but we've got to get this money
situation figured out George uh first
and foremost I just have to ask quickly
uh I'm not trying to get you to share
all the really negative medical news but
I I just I wonder does the medical news
that you got that says the rough is
going to be the road's going to be
really rough
does that road in the prediction of that
road being rough does it make her
finishing school
does it make that A wise choice
that's something we're we're considering
now you know she's gonna be she's gonna
try to be an lmft psychology
um she'll be done with her Bachelors of
spring and wanting to get her master's
but now
um she may have to have brain surgery
and um
yeah so we're trying to figure out you
know what's the best choice moving
forward we don't know yet we still have
to get a test on an MRI and have another
review I I just as you're getting all
that medical information George I I just
think it's wise to press pause on any
more tuition uh the the degree the
Masters will always be there if in fact
we should be pursuing that but this is a
reset right now and this is getting you
guys out of debt and setting you up to
kind of navigate these choppy Waters I
can help you down the road in fact let's
also well let's make sure we schedule
him to call my show where we can go a
little deeper uh on getting him a better
gig George what does he need to do right
now financially so where are you guys at
as far as your bank account you got 15K
in debt what's in the bank
um right now like 60 bucks and 120 bucks
in the savings account okay so we're
going to call this storm mode which
means we're pausing the baby steps we're
going to make minimum payments on our
debts and just keep up with them the
goal is to not have any go to
collections we're just keeping up you
can be proactive with uh with whatever
your lenders are the credit card
companies and say listen my wife is
diagnosed with this medical condition we
don't have the money right now we're
just trying to stay afloat and when you
do that the goal is to stack up as much
cash as possible to put you guys in a
better Financial spot until we know more
until we know what the next step looks
like in this and so what are you making
right now Landscaping
um well because it's seasonal varies
um it's roughly between 60 and 62 after
taxes okay
and when you're not working on on the
seasonal side I would pick something up
right now it doesn't have to be the
dream career path we're going to get you
there maybe it's gonna do some things
but part-time jobs I know you're you're
man you're carrying a lot of weight
right now
um and it's a tough season for you and I
hope there's better days ahead but the
goal right now storm mode stay afloat
stack up cash until you know what's next
once we've got some stability continue
on the baby steps get rid of that debt
get the emergency fund in place that's
the best thing you can do financially
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the Ramsey
Show I'm George Campbell joined by Ken
Coleman this hour if you're listening to
the show I gotta assume that you enjoy
it at least sometimes and if you do like
it here's what I would ask of you
because the show's completely free we're
not taking donations this is not a
Telethon but here's what I do ask would
you consider subscribing to the show
wherever you're listening leaving a
review wherever you're listening and
sharing it with a friend we want to
spread as much hope as we can this year
and one of the ways you do that is
through word of mouth and that's how I
listen to new things is it's got to take
Ken telling me dude you gotta go check
out this show and that's how this stuff
happens that's how life change happens
we appreciate you guys doing that let's
see usually me telling you you got to
buy these pair of shoes that's usually
what it is but can you also you're a
very you're a history buff so you're
always telling me about shows on Netflix
they always start with some year I can't
remember any of them he's like you gotta
watch 1892 and 17.99. well it was the
Yellowstone series you know people know
what I'm talking about and then there's
one you know All Quiet on the Western
Front there's too many too many wars too
many characters can I can't keep up
I now I don't feel like I can trust you
with my recommendations you're gonna
fall asleep during these old old-timey
war movies you're a Sci-Fi guy aren't
you yeah I like action adventure comedy
yeah there we go you mean Jurassic Park
yeah okay big Jurassic fan all right
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Jeff is hanging
out in New Mexico Jeff welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey how's it going great how are you
good good good
how can we help today
well I'm trying to um I'm trying to make
a decision if whether if I should uh buy
a house right now or if I should decide
to um continue to rent right now my
rent's about two thousand two hundred
and uh fifty dollars a month
and um I don't have any credit card debt
the only debt that I do have is
um I own my Jeep and I have student
loans what's left on the Jeep
about 14
000. and what is left on the student
loans
about 84. whoa
well
you called into our show I'll give you
our advice and that is uh until you're
out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund we're not even ready to
start saving up that down payment how
much money do you have saved
about eighty thousand okay well that's
good news at least what's your income
uh roughly about a hundred and thirty
five thousand a year oh wonderful great
shovel there and so the question becomes
if we throw almost all 80 at the debt
that would leave us with 18 Grand
to pay
correct and then making 135 how quickly
could you pay off eighteen thousand
dollars
oh I'd soon probably
three or four months to now think about
that three or four months from now you
don't have any payments and we can save
up that emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses in a few more months
beyond that
be ready to purchase the house and then
so let's say you know you have this goal
saying hey six months from now I want to
pay off all my debt and have an
emergency fund in place now for the next
six months beyond that I'm gonna start
saving up that down payment which by the
way you have freed yourself of all your
payments so you're gonna save up that
down payment really fast
okay and then you go what goal do I need
to have say for this down payment
15-year fixed rate mortgage that's no
more than about a quarter of your
after-tax income monthly and that will
help you figure out how much you need to
put down it could be 10 it could be
twenty percent it could be more have you
looked at homes in in your area that you
would want to purchase
it's been looking around
um
I guess the biggest part was is
and I had I had a idea of what you all
would say I watch your show pretty
frequently but I guess the the part I
was thinking was is man that that rent
is just eating me up and it's just going
it's going nowhere well what's your take
home but you're making 10 grand a month
yeah wrestling about 10 grand and so
that's that 22.50 is less than 25 your
take-home pay and which is reasonable
yeah it feels high but you have a great
income
and when it comes to import you know
when it comes to the mortgage you go
ahead and you're going well the mortgage
could be 22.50 or less but it's a
short-sighted thinking because there's
so much more to worry about as a
homeowner while you've got payments on
here over here with your student loans
and your car payment which adds insult
to injury and a whole lot of stress so
Jeff I I just want to challenge you on
one little mental flip here it's not the
rent that's eating your lunch
it's the debt it's your expenses that's
that's what's doing it so you've got to
live now you know if you want to live
somewhere else where rent is cheaper you
can do that but you the mindset here has
got to be the debt is what's eating my
lunch all those extra payments I gotta
pay something to live somewhere right
that's non-negotiable
so that's the mindset switch so now
because you get distracted if it's like
well the rent's what's dragging me down
so now I gotta go buy a house that's not
what's dragging you down it's the debt
do you understand what I'm saying
I do what are your payments add up to
every month
um roughly
about 15 well it's so it's a 350 payment
on the Jeep and I put down 1500 a month
every time and um on the student loans
I'll put down roughly about a thousand
every month but it's only a 600 payment
so you're throwing 2500 at the debt
right now to pay that off early
right nice that's awesome
so now imagine that being freed up and
that working for you instead of paying
for the past
okay and you start to go all right I'm
gonna be a homeowner soon I just got to
really start to do things one at a time
with focused intensity which means I'm
getting out of debt that is my next A1
which means you know 79 of that 80 000
can be thrown at the debt tomorrow does
that scare you a little bit to have a
thousand in the bank
I like it I like it because guess what
you make 135 000 so you're gonna be okay
if something happened you got a real
emergency you could pause and cash flow
it right
right yeah that's true
so I hope that gives you some peace and
confidence on this plan you got an
amazing income and I just want it
working to build your future instead of
paying for the past which is what it's
doing right now
you're throwing more in payments on the
debt than you are to the rent
that's true and rent gives you Freedom
right now
your HVAC breaks it's not your problem
yep
so uh you're gonna be there no time uh
way faster than most people even with
this pile of debt here you got a bunch
of money in the bank you have an amazing
income and I believe in the next year or
two you will be a homeowner and you're
going to do it with such peace and
Clarity and wisdom and then you're going
to pay it off early because again you're
doing the 15 year and you don't have any
payments except for that mortgage which
is a reasonable mortgage which means
you've got margin to throw extra on that
how old are you
30. 30 years old can I guarantee you by
the time he's 40 this thing's paid off
and uh he's a baby steps millionaire I
agree 100 Jeff how's that feel
a little smile for me to you there we go
there we go we got Jeff smiling Ken
that's a big win I'm telling you this is
big but again I what just happened there
was we just rearranged the pieces of
just of Jeff's life to give him some
hope yeah because right now A lot of
people are just doing too many things at
once they're trying to pay off the debt
but they also want to be homeowners but
they know they should be investing in
the 401K and they've got the match over
here and they want to go on vacation and
you can do all of those things but they
have a time and a place right and so
what you were talking about there is
prioritizing
your focus
and
um you know I like to nerd out on stuff
you get on me about nerding out about
history but I also nerd out I read a lot
of like neurological books and
psychology books of what the way we
think and there's a very famous
psychology study it's it's world
renowned and the short version is they
put
a bunch of people in the room let's say
20 people in a room
and they said here's what we want you we
want you to watch this seven minute
video and it's a bunch of guys doing a
basketball drill where they're passing
the ball all the way up and down the
basketball court what we want you to do
is is focus on how many times the ball
has passed in the seven minute video
that's the only thing sit there with a
pencil and write down every time the
ball is passed so the the respondents
were like okay
halfway through the video they had a guy
in a gorilla costume run out in the
middle of the floor stand in the middle
of the drill for about 30 seconds and
then leave when the video was over the
people running the study came back in
the room and they said
how many times was the ball pass and
every respondent gave their number and
then they said how many of you saw the
gorilla and only two people saw it now
why do I share that
that's pretty wild that's a lesson on
Focus the power of focus they were
focusing only on how many times the ball
had passed so we just got Jeff to a
place where his focus should be and only
on paying the debt off and when we focus
on the right things everything else goes
with it it's maniacal it's successful
what are you focused on that's the
question life lessons from Ken Coleman
involving basketball and gorillas you
can only get that right here on the
Ramsay show wow being a cardigan
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined by my good friend Ken
Coleman and we are here for you America
answering life's biggest questions about
money work purpose and everything in
between
[Music]
888-825-5225 is the number to call Gus
is going to kick us off in Orlando Gus
welcome to the show
hey guys thank you absolutely how can
Ken and I help
uh I'd like to know what you guys think
would be the best for me to do with the
money that I have in my bank account all
right
how much do you have I have I have about
20 000 in it right now and I
have a job that it's a full-time job
that I contribute to my Roth 401k and I
put about 17 percent
into that okay and I've also already
contributed
to my individual Roth the max for 2023
as well
way to go what do you what's your income
uh 73 and a half
great do you have any debt
no okay so we're going to call this 20
your emergency fund plus a little bit
yeah okay well what's your next goal
I'm really not sure because you're
you're at what we would call baby step
four uh how old are you
25 okay are you married
no okay
do you want to be a homeowner
I do but I'm not in a rush
okay what do you want to do
what do you think about doing 10 15 20
years from now because I know you're
thinking about it so don't tell me well
I'm not I don't know no you may not be
sure but I think you got some ideas
hit me yeah basically I just want to
have as much money as quickly as
possible so I don't have to work
as possible what's the what's the rush
when you say as quickly as possible
Melissa I can stop working oh so you're
the part of the fire movement so do you
already hate what you do for work
no I don't hate what I do I would just
prefer to do something other than so
let's say 10 years from now you got a
million dollars Gus and you cannot work
anymore what are you gonna do
I'll probably
just move out west somewhere and go live
in the mountains and hang out just like
be a mountain man just hanging out with
cats
no I'm not cat I'm not a farmer probably
just go hiking snowboarding okay and
then and then outdoor activities all
right and that sounds that's by the way
that's fantastic and then about 60 to 90
days of that you're gonna be bored out
of your skull and you're going to want
to make a contribution to the world
yeah maybe no guaranteed
this idea you've heard of this fire
movement financially independent retire
early is that what this is
ah this is the first time I've heard of
that okay it's a whole movement and
there's a lot of young people doing
there going and it's and it sounds
really wise right work really really
hard make as much money as in a short
period if possible in a short period of
time and then just stop working here's
what I'm trying to tell you young man
and I know you don't believe me yet but
I'm asking you to trust me
we as human beings want to make a
contribution we just want to make the
world a better place in some way do you
do you agree or disagree and I don't
mind if you disagree
no I agree all right then so you go in
and have fun and all that Adventure
stuff that's awesome
but at some point you're gonna wake up
and you're gonna go I'm re I need to do
something besides play
so if you agree with the first statement
that humans long to make a difference in
the world then at some point we want to
do more than play and so so I'm just
curious what have you wondered about
George's George gave you the question
you got a million bucks and you've gone
out west and you've played in the
mountains and hung out and whatever for
who knows how long and then you get
bored and you really want to do
something what is it that you're
thinking about
I have no idea
all right I think I think I'm just
searching to do well I think you got
some you got you got to be confident to
go oh I've thought about this doesn't
mean that's what you're locking into
I've thought about this can I can I just
tell you this and I'll give you back to
George on the money stuff but I really
want to challenge you on this the very
same pull to go hang out in the
mountains and do all that mountainy
outdoorsy stuff the same thing that's
pulling you there I would suggest to you
that you should think about working in
that space
and getting paid to do that kind of
stuff
that's what I think
but what do I do George well I guess on
the money side you're doing incredible
incredibly well yeah 25 you're maxing
out retirement accounts you've got the
savings and investing muscle down are
you renting right now
I currently live at home right now I
just got I've only been working for a
year and
I haven't been wanting to buy anything
and rent where I live is very high and
luckily my parents have been generous
enough to allow me to stay home
so what's the long-term plan to keep
living with Mom and Dad
no I'm planning on moving uh within this
year but I plan on moving out of state
and I'm trying to figure out
uh which city I'd like to live in okay
well that would be your next move
obviously financially and so preparing
for that is important you can start
store that 20 grand in a high yield
savings account you'll get about three
or four percent right now and so that's
the best thing to do with the money you
have currently I would invest 15 right
now you're doing 17. I would slim that
investing back to 15 right now because
we have other goals other than
retirement right now you got a long time
until you can even access those
retirement funds without penalties so
let's start saving up a huge chunk of
cash for you know you're going to need a
deposit you're going to need Furniture
you're going to want to put a down
payment on a home you're going to want
to upgrade the car in the next you know
sounds like he's gonna need a tent you
might need a tent if you're going to be
out west
all right but I would go out on your own
I mean you have a great income even if
you have to get a roommate I think just
getting out on your own even with a
roommate like moving into that adulting
phase gives you such dignity and
Independence that I think you're craving
right now
okay so I I don't know you don't need to
be safe you're in a great financial
position to move out from uh from Mom
and Dad
yeah yeah definitely and if it scares
you a little bit good because that's
gonna be life you're gonna have to start
paying all the bills on your own and I I
think that will give your dollar
something to do and give you a little
more purpose that I think you're craving
right now and can I gift you something
my young friend I want to give you my
book from paycheck to purpose I want you
to to read it listen to it we'll give
you whatever format you want I really
want you to just dial into what's
pulling you out west and all that and
really think about your long-term
contribution that you just go this is
just who I am this is me I've always
been this way this came easy to me I've
always liked this kind of stuff and this
kind of thing this result motivates me
it's really important for young people
all of us to understand that but right
now you're set up to actually be able to
go do it and I want you to dream on that
so hang out for a second yeah you've got
a great foundation and can I just keep
coming back to this quote I don't even
know where it's from but it just go west
young man no that's Gus he's doing it
yeah and I'm proud of him most 25 year
olds they're not doing this kind of
stuff and so you've got a great
financial Foundation now we just got to
put that to use and go what was I
created to do what should I be
contributing to for the next 30 years of
my life great goal this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Ken Coleman
and we are having a good time if you
want to join us call
888-825-5225 it is time now for our
question of the day and it is brought to
you by Cardigans a Timeless and
versatile wardrobe staple that every
serious man needs colorless Timeless
Cardigans what's there not to love Yeah
man good stuff today's question comes
from Jim over in Maryland he says I've
been practicing your ways since I was in
college and I'm in baby steps four and
three B while saving for a big down
payment on a house my parents asked me
for money and have finally admitted to
their debts and their house payment even
though I've known their money situation
for years they were embarrassed to ask
me and were crying they want to get out
of debt and stop forever I offered to
put my parents through Financial Peace
University and I explained to them how
they can get to a point of never having
to ask me or anyone else for money ever
again but only if they were open and
honest about all their debts and
actually go through it together they
want to do it they've accepted it how do
I make sure they do it and how do I hold
them accountable or make them
accountable should I know about their
debts or is this already embarrassing
enough for them should I just gift FPU
and whatever they do with it they do any
help is greatly appreciated
oh man the child is parenting the
parents yeah and that is kind of a
natural progression through life it
really is as the parents get older you
know George I'm curious to know what you
think on this as I was listening to that
I I think he uh
I think he has the answer to that
question and it comes down to this what
is your existing relationship like with
your parents like when you gotta have
real conversations with them what's that
like you he just inherently knows and if
they're really willing and they're
saying we want to do this I think he
goes to them and says says hey I'm
willing to do this
this or this what are you comfortable
with and you know just see where they're
at he can read them he can hear them I
would just approach it that way throw it
all out there as a menu and they can
choose which items they want yeah I like
that I mean we know you you can't force
anyone you can't change anyone uh what
you can do is encourage them you can
coach them and I think you're on the
path to doing that through gifting them
FPU maybe you go through it with them
say hey I'll go I'll I'll come over once
a week we'll do dinner we'll watch the
next lesson we'll talk about it we'll
have a discussion about it and I'll help
you guys get out of this math of this
mess but we don't want to do is enable
them in any way clearly they're at a
point where they're I mean the fact that
the parents are even opening up about
their finances to them they're crying
they're emotional about it I think it
tells me they've had their I've had it
moment yeah I think you're right I agree
I would just be open and honest they'll
tell you what they're comfortable with
and what they're not and if they ask for
your advice give it to them yeah
otherwise you know Dave calls it powder
butt syndrome they're not going to
listen to the kid who they powder their
butt 20 years ago and so that's a hard
thing for a kid to give a parent
Financial advice but the fact that
you're living this out to the point
where they're coming to you because of
how you've managed your finances uh
number one you're changing your family
tree and number two I think it's very
honorable to your parents to want to
help them in this way and gifting them
fbu is a great great start yeah so way
to go Jim yeah but it's a sad situation
uh parents out there
you can do better you you don't have to
go to your kids asking them for money
that's not what you want later on in
life and it's part of why we tell people
hey focus on your own retirement before
you try to help your kid get on get on
their feet because this is what happens
the parents didn't prepare well they
weren't in a good Financial spot now
they're knocking on the kid's door
saying hey we need five grand can we
borrow some money
yeah so not what you want all right
let's go to the phones Julie joins us up
next in Grand Junction Colorado Julie
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call happy Friday
um I am looking forward to your advice
on my situation so uh during the
pandemic both hubby and I lost our jobs
uh hubby has been able to find a new job
I've been able to find a new job just by
reaching out to
um someone else that I knew who was
wanting to set up a non-profit doing
what I had been doing 10 years previous
to that and so of course during that
time when we were looking for jobs and
trying to navigate the pandemic we've
got two teenagers and we went about
thirty thousand dollars into debt
and
um that didn't feel great and we never
had done FPU before but now that we both
have two jobs we went through FPU last
fall and we finished up
um this in December and we're in baby
step two we've paid off close to eight
grand since December so that's like in a
month which feels great awesome
I the
designed as a part-time job setting up a
new non-profit my pay is being sponsored
by the people who run the organization
um and the organization doesn't have
enough funding just yet in order to pay
for me to be full-time doing the job
it's super fulfilling it's non-profit
work it's amazing stuff feeling good
every single day when you come home
and I've recently been contacted by a
recruiter in the area who could triple
my income if I worked with her did
something not non-profit and
um
did what I'm doing now basically but on
a full-time level and in the for-profit
sector it might help to know that I'm 54
hubby is 58 so we go
what are you this sounds really great
but you're not sure why no I'm I'm
really really struggling because with
what I love what I do so much but I
thought I heard you say I'm sorry but I
thought I heard you say that the new job
offer would be doing what you're doing
now
somewhat but not for non-profits so what
is the difference of type work of the
administrative type work but not for the
you know good of other people all right
so that directs so it's the mission of
this non-profit it's not the fact that
it's not a profit it's the missional
piece yes okay and do you mind just
telling me very quickly what the what
the what the result is for people that
this non-profit is producing that you
are so connected to
they get an assistance dog
okay so I got an idea well I got one
more question
I feel like a lawyer in front of a judge
uh one more question your honor
um
how quickly how how dramatically
would tripling your income change
everything that you want how much better
I mean I just want you to describe that
to me how much better would it make
things
yeah um we could get out from underneath
this debt like in six months and then we
could start working on the other baby
steps because we don't have any of those
good and how great would that feel
amazing okay I would be able to like
completely change my entire family tree
okay I'm so excited I've got an idea and
I hope you like it are you ready okay
I'm ready I want you to let me finish
and then tell me what you think here we
go
I think you should take the job offer
from the recruiter that triples your
income fast forwards the baby steps and
and and and and
and one more aunt and then you volunteer
for the non-profit that you love so much
because they always need volunteers and
you still have a connection to placing
assistance dogs to help people so you
don't lose the connection
but you make the money
now you can tell me what you think of my
idea be gentle
no I actually think it sounds amazing
because I think as you know when you're
working every day helping other people
yes it's super fulfilling but it also
draws on you right you know there's a
cost emotionally
um and I think that sounds like a really
great idea and I hadn't thought of it
before so there's no butts here you're
gonna do it
um I gotta run it by hubby trust me let
me go ahead and speak on behalf of hubby
he's gonna like it
it's kind of a it's just it's a family
decision I mean I've kind of been
talking to Hubby about this a little bit
and he's like but you haven't given this
enough chance and I know how happy this
makes you yeah here's the deal you're
not going to lose the happy you're going
to volunteer maybe a couple nights of
the week or on weekends you're an
administrative whiz you're already using
your administrative talent to make that
non-profit work better for the ultimate
result and so you're gonna keep doing it
but you're gonna do it as a volunteer
get the Fulfillment that contribution
that's what I'm talking about you were
created to make a difference and you can
do that plus make triple get out of debt
and live the life you've always dreamed
thank you get that Financial Foundation
this year it's a building year yeah and
then you're ready to do whatever you
want if you want to work at that
non-profit for very little pay later
down the road you have the ability to do
that because you set yourself free
financially I love it great advice Ken
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey show it's a
new year and that means new goals and so
many of you have got that new career on
the goal list and you gotta check out
the get clear career assessment by my
friend and America's career Coach Ken
Coleman this assessment will help you
find fulfillment in your current job
know the career you were created for and
uncover your passions and talents if
you're choosing quiet quitting over
there because you're uh you want to make
a change you don't know where to start
I'm telling you the get clear assessment
is a great place to start the whole
thing will take you 15 or 20 minutes
answer some questions minutes later
you'll get a custom report that
describes what truly drives you your top
strengths and possible careers that
would be a great fit for you so you can
start by getting that get clear
assessment at ramseysolutions.com get
clear yeah it's a it's a it's it's
honestly my life's work to be able to
give people self-awareness really
quickly all we're doing is asking you
deep but very simple but deep questions
about you and for many people they just
see themselves the way now the world has
been seeing them for a long time and uh
your your the opportunity to be great is
totally based on your ability to know
how unique you are so your your
uniqueness is where we find greatness
and we want to help you do that and a
lot of derivatives but simply put you're
going to experience more meaning and
make a lot more money so check it out
it's a great tool all right let's go to
the phones Carrie joins us up next in
Mobile Alabama Carrie welcome to the
show
hey good good afternoon
um I just wanted your
input as far as if you were in my
situation what you would you would do
I'm a single parent
um I'm in the middle of bankruptcy
and
I my car isn't working so my car's down
um and I was just served papers for
eviction
um I'm not
um I'm not currently working
okay moment it's okay take your time
Carrie
you're under it right now oh I've been
really prayed about calling and I
honestly didn't think I would get
through well you were supposed to get
I'm the enemy because I'm Gonna Come On
Top I'm not going to get through this
yeah you are
um
I'm 51 I have two children and they're
it's a really long story but their
father is not involved how old how old
are the kids
um my youngest two are 11 and he's on
the Spectrum and then I have a
seven-year-old daughter okay
are you so I just see are you able to
work
um I have some
um some uh issues physically
um but I have in the past
um but I'm home now because I had to
retain attorney for my son for an IEP I
don't have to pay for that like it it's
free
um right to children with IDs so
um
so I'm in the process of that but if I
were to call you and uh an hour from now
and say hey I got a job for you
are you able to go do the job
assuming it does not have all the
physical limitations but could you work
my car isn't working like it's been down
since before Christmas I had the
batteries I'm sorry I get it but can you
work or do you have child like who would
watch the kids that's what I'm trying to
say I mean we got to figure out you
don't so it's just me correct so you
couldn't work out of the house
theoretically right cool you have no
friends and family that could watch the
kids
no
okay so the only work that you could do
because we've got to get some income in
here right is is when you're working
remotely right
correct okay
because then you don't have to have
transportation so because we got to get
some income in here because you're
getting evicted you got a lot coming
your way yeah have you looked into do
you have a bankruptcy trustee that
you're working with
um I had I called him today and he
recommended
um filing chapter 13 because I have a
payment each month
and and the only reason I went that way
was to keep my vehicle
um but he suggested
um file in Chapter 13 and getting rid of
that
100 000 debt and just what's the hundred
thousand dollar debt
um medical bills
um that's why I filed bankruptcy because
I was so overwhelmed with the payments
and I couldn't
I just couldn't do it now when you say
you're in the middle of bankruptcy how
far are you in the process
um I've already appeared in court okay
um and I missed like two payments and
the judge said that he wanted to see
like consistency as far as the payments
before it got
like totally was this while you had no
income
yes I mean I get SSI and my son gets SSI
so I do have
is that even enough to cover your rent
um I live in uh subsidized housing it's
based off my income okay so how much is
your rent
currently it's
um ninety three dollars okay but you're
getting evicted from that housing
correct from being behind
um
just from being behind the 93 payment
smart yes
so are you going to be able to get other
subsidized housing now
I
I've been in contact with them
um and they stated in the papers that
they notified me to pay the rent before
the fifth and they did not I mean I knew
the rent was due by the fifth I
understand that
and I've always paid my bills or I've
made arrangements so I mean could you
fix this by saying all right I'm going
to come up with the 93 dollars for last
month and the 93 for this month and get
you back current or are they just saying
have you tried to negotiate with them
I have what'd they say I've been a fair
and I've called them and he referred me
to the courthouse
okay I would work with your bankruptcy
trustee to figure out what your options
are what the laws are I don't want
anyone bullying you around with this but
you're A1 right now is food utilities
shelter and transportation that's it
that's all I want Carrie focused on and
making sure those kids have food on the
table and a roof over their heads and
whatever you have to do to do that even
if it's a work from home job or you
borrow a car are you part of a local
Church community in Mobile
um I am not okay I used to live there
there are so many great churches there
you've got to get plugged in with the
church let them know your situation uh
do you have any family or friends that
would be able to help
to cover your bills for a month
that would help me financially no
I'm
okay well you you've got to have
Community here yeah you can't do this
alone right now and we've your next step
is to get that income up as Ken said
because we don't need a lot to survive
right now and we're just in survival
mode uh but that's what we need to focus
on is where are we going to live next
can we make sure we're not evicted can
we negotiate with them can we scrape by
200 bucks can we get in touch with a
local Church community or a Ministry out
there that can help me right now it's
not can we it's we will carry can I just
speak to your mama heart right now
yes I don't know
stronger human being on the planet than
a single mom I just don't
you're a warrior you're a mama bear
would you let anybody harm those kiddos
absolutely not no
then I want you to harness that and I
know you have been through unbelievable
unbelievable storms
but you better summon your mama bear
right now
and if somebody came to harm those
babies you had died protecting them and
right now what is harming those babies
and harming you
is your financial instability you can
work you must work you go back to that
deadbeat government employee and say I'm
going to come up with 186 dollars you
find a way you fight you go get a remote
job you fight you go to a church and say
I'll come to church every Sunday morning
with these kids I need a battery in my
car you fight for those kids you fight
for you now
amen Well Carrie hang on the line we are
going to connect you with a financial
coach and we're going to pay for that
session so they can dig into the details
and walk with you through this we are
here for you please call us back
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day comes from Romans 12 10.
be devoted to one another in love honor
one another above yourselves
the great Fred Rogers once said love and
success always in that order it's that
simple and that difficult
well folks do you know how much you're
gonna need in retirement do you know
where you should be investing in today's
economy it may sound more of a pipe
dream than a real possibility but it is
possible to retire early with some hard
work and intentional planning we've got
eight steps on how to retire early in
this weekend's edition of the Ramsey
newsletter it's completely free and you
can sign up for it at
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter and you'll get it every
Sunday and find out those eight steps to
retire early George I want to point out
that our quote of the day was from none
other than Mr Rogers the ultimate
cardigan icon
I mean legendary the zip up card I don't
know that anybody's ever done it better
than he did he innovated in the cardigan
space with the zip up cardigan well what
I like is he walked in he pulled it out
of the closet put it on while he's
walking down the stairs showed the kids
how to neatly put that cardigan sweater
zipper together and just he was flawless
I wish I could say we planned that but
you can't produce that kind of magic you
know we couldn't plan that
wow oh man we're having too good of a
time is there like a national cardigan
sweater makers Association I should be
their keynote I would pay good money to
see you do yeah yeah it probably doesn't
exist they're all wearing Cardigans in
the crowd yeah uh all right let's go to
the phones will is in Burlington
Virginia well welcome to the show
uh how's it going actually it's Vermont
but uh oh I'm doing pretty well sorry
the abbreviation was wrong on my screen
you know someone's getting fired over
that I'm just kidding no it's all right
I thought I was like I didn't know there
was a Burlington Virginia but it's all
right how we doing well what can I help
with today
I'm doing pretty well I'm actually uh
pretty new to your guys's shell here
I've been listening for about a month
now
a buddy of mine turned you know onto it
um made a lot of stupid decisions
financially over the years uh once I
started making you know really good
money I just and stupid stuff
um it's called lifestyle creep so before
yeah yeah
[Music]
um so before I found you guys I was in
the process of getting uh solar put on
my house
and in doing that was taking a whole
monthly loan so everything you know came
back I've been listening to you guys I'm
on baby step two hammering down as much
as I can
and I'm kind of at a point where I don't
know if I should go through with the
solar loan and get the solar put on
because
I'll be saving money on utilities
or if I should just cancel well you're
too smart for this buddy you know too
much now
yeah you're saying it's not too late to
back out of this nightmare
no I'll lose 300 bucks but it's it's not
a big deal I'll pay that stupid tax to
not pay a much bigger stupid tax by
taking out this HELOC to pay for solar
what's your utility bill
well
um I'm a HVAC guy so I put heat pumps in
this year this month was 512 dollars
give me the average if you divided it
out over 12 months it's not 500 bucks a
month
no if I average it out it's probably
300. okay
that is 3 600 bucks a year what are you
saving
30 bucks a month you're saving 30 bucks
a month
yeah it'd be 270.
okay this hurts my brain you're saving
30 a month which is 360 a year you're
saving
well right but then when the loans paid
off I won't have to pay for electricity
okay
we're gonna take out
like total amount yeah
it was 37 I believe 37 000. what's the
interest rate variable probably
no no it was fixed at uh 3.99
so you were going to take out a 37 000
loan at four percent interest to save
360 a year
well long term I'm not going to have an
electric bill you're not going to be
alive by the time you Roi on this thing
true
look I'm doing the math for you which I
I wish the guy trying to sell you the
HELOC did or the guy selling you the
solar uh 37 000 right this is not even
counting interest it would take you 102
years to break even will
okay how old are you I figured but
what's your name 34. do you plan on
living to be 136 years old to see the
light of day when you Roi on this
no
did you hear what George said I mean the
if there's only one thing you heard by
calling another show today and I'm glad
you did I'm glad you're a new listener
is the amount of time it would take you
to Roi on that 37 000 a hundred plus
years he said I mean do you need to know
anything else with the sales guy didn't
tell you that
okay but I got an idea no I was just
thinking I wouldn't have a electric or
heating bill but that's fine but that's
not true you would still have a bill
uh there was a national news program
that did a whole story on this because
it doesn't completely remove your
there's still a cause like it doesn't
completely wipe your energy out you need
to do the research on it actually you
don't because we already explained why
you should eat the 300 bucks and not
worry about it right I'm sure the solar
panel salesman told you otherwise yeah
but I just did some third grade napkin
math to show you that you won't live to
see the day you Roi on this but I have
an idea I have an idea to loot to to
lessen the sting of eating the 300
dollars
you're gonna eat the 300 you're not
going to go into debt for it but uh
you're going to cash flow some solar
walking lights along the front path of
your house at Lowe's or Home Depot go
get you some of those yeah now you got
some solar energy
sorry I'm just telling this whole solar
panel thing is the next great scam
it really is yeah and people are falling
for it because they're going well yeah
utility bills are high I could save a
quick Buck if I do this by going 40
Grand into debt and Roi 100 years from
now
right and I was taking into
consideration my heating bill because
now I've got heat pumps in the house
heat pump water here so I was like
taking that into consideration as well
you know my heating bill during the
winters three four hundred dollars a
month so I was like well
maybe this will work out but then like I
said I found you guys I'm like
rethinking everything I'm so glad well
here's the deal you could save up thirty
seven thousand dollars and pay cash for
it and then you got what you want
without
the 100 Year Roi
right I'm gonna get rid of the 60 000 in
debt first so there we go of course
we're just kind of helping your data 60
Grand
that's it I had 72
um before I started listen to you guys I
I sold a car that I wasn't really using
good hammered off two two things and now
I've got a another question is I've got
a uh a new vehicle for my wife and I
have a company Vehicles so I don't have
to pay for those but like I'm I'm even
at the point where I'm like well maybe I
should just sell this and then
get a cheaper vehicle you know what's
the loan on that vehicle we're talking
now we're making progress what's the
loan amount on that new vehicle
uh we owe 45 000 on it and it's 820 is
that on top of your 60
no that's included in the 60s what's the
car worth
uh about 45. I'm getting rid of that
thing
sell it what's your household I don't
have the cash I don't have the cash to
go and buy another vehicle and we need
one for her so what do you have in
savings
a thousand okay and what's your
household income
uh two hundred thousand good grief you
make two hundred thousand dollars
save up six grand like I said take your
next paycheck get Mama an Uber for a
month or two good grief at 800 a month
payment you're still coming out I mean
you realize how ridiculous an 800 car
payment is for a depreciating asset
oh yeah I had three car payments at one
point in time and I I what are you
trying to outdo me
no I just you know stupid and I start
making money
you're not stupid people who make 200
Grand aren't stupid you're a smart guy
that's right you're just falling for the
traps of these scummy sales people
you're falling for the traps of a toxic
money culture and the good news is you
you know too much now you're a dangerous
man with some money in your pocket and
you're about to pay off all this debt be
completely debt free and uh we are
rooting for you my man thanks for the
call that puts this hour of the Ramsay
show in the books my thanks to my
cardigan wearing co-host Ken Coleman he
rocks it like no one else my thanks to
all the folks in the booth will James
Austin Zach Andrew they're all in there
keeping the show float and you America
thanks for tuning in until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]